es soll ein friedlicher Protest sein
diese Menschen auf telavivs Straßen
stellen den Krieg in Frage unter ihnen
auch whrdienst verweigernde für die klar
ist im Gazakrieg Kämpfen auf keinen Fall
den Dienst an der Waffe verweigern für
viele hier in Israel ein Tabuthema Ella
ist Transfrau 17 Jahre alt hat ihren
Einberufungsbescheid schon
bekommen ich will mich
nicht
ich will das jzige System bekämpfen und
ich denke der einzige Weg dies wirksam
zu tun ist nicht daran
teilzunehmen war 87 Tage in Haft weil
sie den Militärdienst verweigerte die
20jährige hat schon vor dem 7 Oktober
die Politik Israels in Frage
gestellt ichich mich selbst
friedensak nicht in der Armee dien ich
werde niemals in einer gewalttätigen
Organisation sein vor allem nicht wenn
diese ein anderes Land besetzt wir
können unmöglich Sicherheit für eine
Nation erringen wenn das auf Kosten
einer anderen
geschieht vielleicht kein Platz mehr in
der Gesellschaft zu haben etwas das Ella
auch Angst macht das dien ist ein großer
Teil der israelischen Kultur und werden
wir uns dem verweigern stellen wir uns
außerhalb dieser Gesellschaft ich Gren
mich vom nationalistischen und
ab und öffne mich für den eher linken
und ungebundenen Teil der
Gesellschaft eine Symbolfigur der
Bewegung ist Tal mitnik er ist 18 Jahre
alt auch er verweigert den Militärdienst
er glaube so sagt er im Social Media
Video der verbrecherische Angriff
Israels auf Gaza werde das grausame
Gemetzel dass die Hamas angerichtet hat
nicht aufheben Gewalt sei keine Lösung t
ist inzwischen in Arrest seine Anwältin
erzählt er fühle sich trotz der Haft
erleichtert nicht in diesen Krieg zu
ziehen er wollte dass die Menschen in
Israel und in der Welt wissen dass man
Israeli sein kann und trotzdem gegen das
was Israel dem palästinensischen Volk
antut man muss nicht in irgendeiner Form
antiisraelisch oder antisemitisch sein
um Israel für Kriegsverbrechen zu
kritisieren der verpflichtendehdien
Gehör DNA der israelischen Gesellschaft
die meisten jüdischen Israelis werden im
Alter von 18 Jahren einberufen Männer
dienen zweieinhalb Jahre Frauen Z Jahre
ausgenommen sind nur ultraorthodoxe
Juden und arabische
Israelis für ihr Land im Krieg zu
kämpfen für die meisten
selbstverständlich vor allem
jetzt das ist sehr wichtig wir müssen es
tun wenn wir es nicht tun wird niemand
für uns kämpfen
es ist keine Option nicht zur Armee zu
gehen nicht jetzt ich verstehe dass es
Leute gibt die nicht gut zur Armee
passen in das System aber aus
moralischen Gründen nicht zu gehen damit
bin ich nicht
einverstanden die Situation in der wir
in Israel leben ist sehr
schrecklich aber es ist wichtig und wir
verteidigen unser
Land offizielle Zahlen zu
whrdienstverweigernden gibt es nicht die
israelische Armee will sich auf Anfrage
nicht äußern als Linker Vordenker kennt
is minuhin die Szene er selbst diente
als Major später weigerte er sich als
Reservist in den Kampf zu ziehen war in
Haft seit dem 7 Oktober hätten ihn
allein 25 Reservisten um Rat gebeten die
nicht in diesen Krieg ziehen
wollen die versucht im Moment zu zeigen
dass alle kommen aber in Wirklichkeit
gibt este wild sind zur Armee zu gehen
obwohl die Armee sie
einberuft ich denke der patriotischste
Akt im Moment ist es den Wehrdienst zu
verweigern bereit zu sein ins Gefängnis
zu gehen und sich zu weigern an diesem
schrecklichen kriegteil zu nehmen der
sich systematisch gegen Zivilisten in
Gaza
richtet in einem linken Club in telaviv
treffen sich die Aktivisten auch hier
hören wir werrdienst verweigern hat
nicht nur mit dem 7 Oktober zu tun eine
Friedensbewegung die auf den Dialog mit
den Palästinensern setzt den Kurs der
aktuellen Regierung
anprangert warum haben sich
Organisationen wie die Hamas so gut
etablieren können dass sie so stark
geworden sind und so viel Macht gewonnen
haben liegt auch an der Art und Weise
wie Israel das palästinensische Volk
misshandelt wer verweigert muss mit
beruflichen Nachteilen rechnen und es
hat auch Folgen für das Privatleben
die meisten meiner Freunde sind Soldaten
also zu sagen du stehst dagegen und
verweigerst dich das bedeutet schon dass
man in gewisser Weise allein
ist Außenseiterin sein für Ella kein
neues Gefühl eine Erfahrung die sie auch
schon als tranzfrau gemacht
hat wenn wir uns bereits gegen
vorgegebene Normen in der Gesellschaft
wen wenn wir uns gegen sie wen müssen um
uns in unserem Leben wohl
sind wir vielleicht eher bereit auch
sonst Widerstand zu
leisten sie wollen ihre Stimme erheben
und nicht die Waffen und so Widerstand
leisten für ihr Land denn so sagt Ella
sie sei stolze israelen sie will das
Land und die Gesellschaft
ändern